Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Final Nights 3
Now, this is a Five Nights at Freddy's fan game, but this is just a demo.
I don't know if I'm going to be playing the full game,
and I'm not going to be going back and playing 1 and 2 of this series,
but a lot of you guys said that this one was very well made.
And I'm not opposed to playing these Five Nights at Freddy's fan games.
Hello. Oh, am I not -  Am I not pressing on the right area?
[Yells] Whoa there we go, okay.
So I don't want to make a habit of playing too many of these, but I want to give credit where credit is due.
Because, I do like Indie horror developers.
I do like Indie game developers in general, and I like to see what people can create out of these things.
And see what unique spin-
And people said that this one had a BIT of new creativity to it.
So we're going to see exactly what they mean by that very soon, no doubt.
What?
What was that? OH, I'M IN AN AMBU- Oh, hello.
WHOA... [Chuckles]
Whoa!
Nicely done!
Oooh.
Oh, I'm being wheeled in on a gurney!
Oh, I had idea about this.
I've been through this one too many times in my life, if you ask me.
Wait, how many times..?
How many times have I been wheeled in on a gurney into a hospital?
It was once for burning my fingers...
There was once when I was about to get my tumor removed.
There was another time...
Ah, when I passed out and I can't drink anymore, that's why. Okay.
That was the-
I think about three times.
Let's see.
[Reading] "Hello, it's me, your best friend! To survive, use these tips.
"You must sleep to progress. No sleeping if reapers are in.
"Scare away puppet man when he's closest!
"Close closet!
"Close door when my friend is closest!
"Sleep tight. Your time is not up!
"Yet.    -Fredbear"
Thanks, buddy! That doesn't reassure me in any capacity,
But I'm gonna see what can happen.
OKAY...
Oh, night one. Now, this is just the demo...
And once again, when the full game comes out, I don't think I'm gonna be doing a full playthrough of this.
I'm gonna save my next full playthrough of a Five Night At Freddy's game for when Sister location comes out.
Holy shit...
Whoa.
You want- WHOA!
What the hell?
Okay, I don't know the controls, so I apol- I'm gonna die.
I- I can already predict it, I'm gonna die.
What the hell do I do? Do I not even need the mouse?
Okay, mouse, fuck that.
What do I do?
I don't know what to- WHOA.
HEY! HI!
What do I do? I don't know what to do.
OHHHH GOD.
I can't go under my bed. What do I do about that?
HI!!!
What are you doing outside my window?
Are you cleep- creepin- creep-cleepering in?
Oh god, how do I scare away puppet man?
[Singsong] I don't knooooww. I don't know the controllls
I'm pushin lots of buttons, please don't murder me.
Fuck.
Ahh, he's getting closer. Hey!
AHHH SHIT.
I'm fucked. [Thunder]
Hi.
Hi, ju- [Sputters] I'll be with you in a second.
I know that for a fact.
Do I need to click anywhere? Is that what I need to do?
[Ominous sound]
Hiii.
HOW'S IT GOIN?
I'm just gonna stare death in the face, cause I got no other alternative!
BOY, YOU GOT A LOVELY SMILE!!!
I LOVE THE WAY YOUR SHOULDERS ALL COME UP INTO A BATMAN SYMBOL!
[Ominous laughter] Eeugh, that ain't good.
[Laughter continues] AAAHHH!!
Oh, god, I'm dead, I'm dead,
HIIII, HOW'S IT GOIN? HI!
What are you? Balloon Boy?!
[Screams] FUCK OFF
[Chuckling] Hello. Okay... Game over!
I'm dead!
I don't know how to play.
How do you play???
How do you play?!?!
I don't know how to play!!!
Okay... Alright, I'm not gonna use that as an excuse.
I'm gonna go figure out the controls!
I'll be right back!
Alright, so I couldn't figure out what exactly I was supposed to do...
I went to the website, I went in the games, I... I don't know the controls!
So I'm gonna - There's gonna be a lot of experimentation going on here.
Okay. These do nothing. That does nothing.
That does nothing!
Mouse buttons do nothing! Oh, wait -
Whoa. Wait, what was that?
What did I do? Ooh. Where did I go?
Where did I go? Where am I? Where - Ohh..kay...
Eeugh, back up! Okay. What am I doing?
AAAHH!! YOU'RE BACK!
Oh, shit. Fuck, man!
How do I - Eeugh, I don't knooow what I'm supposed to be doing.
Why can't I go forward now?
What?
What?!
Ohh... Aah!
Oh - FUCK ME. COME ON!!!
DO SOMETHING!!!
Come on! Follow me!
Take my hand! Follow me!!!
Come on!!!
Follow me!!! [Thunder] I'm gonna die again, that's just what's gonna happen!
[Singsong] Cause I caaan't mooove any - Is that something?
Ooh.
S - Seems like something!
[Ominous noise] That ain't good.
Hi!!! Okay. Fuck me, then.
Alright. I'm fucked, I'm fucked,I'm fucked, I'm fucked.
Aw, I'm fucked.
[Ominous laughter]
[Screams] Got ya. Okay.
I got YOU! You didn't get me. I got YOU.
. . .
Oh.
What???
What am I doing?
What am I doing??
What am I doing???
What is happening? I don't know what's happening.
Is this relating to sleeping?
Is this good?
I don't know!!!
I can't - I can't do anything!
I guess this is good!!!
I think...? I'm not a hundred percent sure -
Why is my hair so weird? Ah, my hair's so weird today!
[Screams]
[??????]
[???????]
Okay. Anyway.
I don't know what's happening.
I don't know why this is happening.
I don't know what's supposed to be happening.
I'm not a hundred percent sure about anything.
[Thunder] Fuuuck me then. Okay.
Lightning! You gonna spook me? Huh?!
That's one intimidating clock right there!
A great big clock,
Coming to - [Ominous sound] That ain't a good sound.
I can't do anything!!!
I'm pressing buttons!!!
[Screams]
. . .
Uh-oh. That ain't good.
I got my DEFENSES at maximum!
MAAAXIMUM EFFICIENCY!!!
Nobody better come at me!
Nobody better come at me!!!
Yay???
[Clock tolls] Wooooo!!!
I did something! [Laughing] I don't know what I did!
What did I do???
What did I dooo?!?!
[Thunder] Oh, jeez.
Jeezums.
Alright.
[Reading] "Their aggression rises."
NOOO FRICKIN JOKE.
Nice grid paper, by the way. I always appreciated good grid paper.
As a former engineering student,
I... like grid paper.
OKAY!
Night two. For a demo, I didn't expect it to have more than one night.
Probably just gonna have two nights.
I don't know when the full game is gonna be released, or how many nights are gonna be in the full game!
Okay, so if I hit space here...
It sleeps.
But if I hit space again - Okay, now it does something.
Okay, so if I hit forward...
OOOH! It IS clicking!
Oh, it IS clicking!
[Ominous sound] Oh, hey.
Hey, stop that! Youuu stop it now!
[Thunder] OHHH
Okay. I don't understand!!!
[Singing] Don't knooow what I'm supposed to dooo!
Oh, that's not good.
I - [Sputters] oh...
AWW, FUCK OFF!
What the hell? Man, this is so weird!
Either something's buggy with MY game, where I can't click properly -
Let me try one more thing to adjust this. I'll be right back.
I want to make this work, I really do.
Okay, so I'm back in the game, and I changed it - Uh, had to tweak with the settings a bit,
So I'm gonna try to sleep a little bit.
Get up,
Go out there, and try to figure out what the hell I'm supposed to do.
So I'm gonna sleep till one o' clock
Cause I need my beauty rest.
Markimoo needs a lot of beauty rest, 'cause I'm fuckin' UGLY
Anyway.
So, wake up. Go out there,
Go over here. Woooo!!! There we go!
What is that?
What i - [Clunk]
I'm thunkin something! [Clunk]
Oh, I'm thunking the SHIT out of this thunky thunker!
That's a thunke - WOAH.
What???
What was that???
Did I have that the whole time?
[Clank]
What?!?!
What am I doing? [Clunk]
I can't see a - [Ominous sound] ...goddamn thing. Oh shit how do I get out of this?
...Okay.
Well, that ain't good. [Thunder]
[Unimpressed yell]
Hello!
BOO!
AH FUCK YOU
[Chuckling] What the fuck??? Why did I go CONFRONT HIM?
Oh, jeez! I didn't mean to do THAT.
Ah, shit.
Alright, then! Here's another go.
[Screams]
FLOOF THE HAIR!
FOR POWER!!!
That's floofy.
My floof is getting floofy.
And I'm gonna try this again because now I got it working.
Now the controls are ACTUALLY working.
So I can actually play the game.
I don't know what happened to my flashlight. It only appeared for like two seconds.
And then it completely "ethploded."
Right, whatever. "Their aggression rises," I don't give a SHIT.
Heh.
[Ominous sound]
Alright...
Okay bye, then!
[Thunder] Ohhh, that ain't good.
So, what do I do about you? NOO!!!
NO, DON'T - GET BACK!!! AAAHHH!!!
Ohh, jeez... Do I scare him?!
Did I spook you by screaming in your face and such?
I'm going back into bed.
Fuck this shit.
Fuck this shit, I'm out! I'm out, bitches!
I'm out! I'm outie!!
I'm just gonna take a nice nap. No one's gonna mess with mee!
No one's gonna mess with - [Gasp]
Okay! [Middle finger defense]
[Thunder] Ohhh shit.
That ain't good.
I really am expecting something to pop out, but apparently nothing wants to say hi to me.
Who wants to interrupt me? I must be so adorable when I sleep.
I should set up a camera and watch myself as I slumber.
That wouldn't be creepy.
Well!
[Clock tolls]
I WIN!
Again!
[Chuckling] Whaaat?
Okay...!
I don't know if I'm just getting lucky,
Or if something horrible is about to happen to me.
Wow!
That was it. Hang on, I'm going back in.
I'm gonna go back in, because something ain't right here.
There's something going on.
The flashlight is not working properly.
I do not know what's happening.
So it's starting over from the beginning.
So I really want to see what is going on.
Who the - ?
I don't even know who's IN here, it's like, some weird version of the puppet outside.
Still got a stick for your puppet. The scary puppet. 'Cause he's a scarecrow puppet.
Alright, whatever.
So there's three main a -
Whoa  - hey...
So what do I do about you?
[Screams] Hello. Goodbye.
[Chuckling] So what do I do besides just pop out and say hi?
'Cause holy shit.
Oh, that - There's something there.
Hello. [Light clicks] Eeugh. Can I - ? Thank you.
Shut that on your hand, please.
[Light clicks] Still in there? Alright, you're gone.
So, what do I do about...?
. . .
Is there anything in there?
Okay. Well, that ain't good. So, what happens?
Do I need to go on my bed? Eeugh.
Go on the bed.
Go on the bed!
Go on the bed!!!
[Ominous sound]
Aah!!
. . .
...Okay!
Did that take care of the thing?!
Can I see shadows in the darkness?!
I think it's gone!
Probably!
Yes!!! It's in the room.
Fuck!!!
[Laughing] Oh, god damn it.
[Screams]
Goodbye!!!
I thought the door was open there for a second, okay. That ain't good.
[Light clicks] Ka-BAM! Schlam it on your fingers!
That's what you get - [Screams]
[Laughing] Okay, alright. I guess I'm dead.
Alright.
So, I have a moderate understanding of this game.
When I get - went into it, it was very confusing.
Maybe because I haven't played the first two, I don't know the mechanics fully well.
But... It - It's a bit interesting in that there seems to be a lot going on...
But it's a little convoluted as to what's - What it's all about.
I do appreciate the darkness, but there's also so much darkness that I don't even know what environment I'm in.
So, there's some things that I would personally change,
But that doesn't mean that it's not good, because I don't know the whole series.
So, this was Final Nights. It seems pretty good, it's actually well made.
It's made in the Unreal Engine, so it's graphically a little bit better as far as the shadows and lighting goes.
Modelling - You know, that's up to the game developer and how much work he  wants to put in it,
How many stock assets - Whatever, that's not important.
But this was Final Nights. So I'll leave the opinions up to you guys.
Let me know what you thought of it in the comments down below.
I think it was pretty good! It was a little convoluted, but maybe a little bit of confusion is actually not a bad thing.
It wasn't as scary as some of the other Five Nights at Freddy's fan games that I played in the past,
But then again, I don't think it emphasizes much on jumpscares.
I think it was more about the dread, and seeing your enemies coming closer.
But who knows.
So anyway.
Thank you, everybody, so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you...
In the next video! Bye-bye!